[Music]
[Music]
it's a name that needs no introduction
it's a series not much younger than
video games themselves and by now you've
probably heard breath of the wild the
newest century in the story pantheon of
the Nintendo's iconic franchise is not
just good its revolutionary it redefines
what a Zelda game can be removing three
decades of tradition with both minor
mechanics and major overarching system
and it single-handedly rekindled a
Nintendo flame that's slowly been fading
for years now but breath of the wild is
also a massive open world game and any
video game landscape replete with
formulaic retreads of the same go here
do this structure we've come to expect
in these titles this new Zelda could not
have arrived at a better time
as I make my way across this treacherous
new Hyrule I can't shake the feeling
that everything is about to change
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
understand why breath of the wild is a
benchmark for open-world games it's
probably helpful to first look at its
significance in the Zelda series the
Zelda formula has long been about
finding tools which act as keys to new
areas funneling you from one space to
another
you also descend into dungeons these
discrete locations with environmental
puzzles a new piece of equipment and a
boss that tests your skill with set
equipment once you've completed enough
dungeons you can travel to the game's
final boss usually some form of the evil
king Ganon and beat the game the
structure has always worked and has led
to some amazing games but it's gotten
old when the original Zelda released in
1986 it was a testament to what video
games could do they could transport us
to another place when we could explore
on a whim where we could venture off the
beaten path of 2d side-scroller x' and
confined interior settings it's ironic
but up until breadth of the wild the
Zelda game that offered you the most
freedom was the first Zelda game they
capture the joy of pure exploration
venturing into the woods out of
curiosity crossing a river to see what
lies on the opposite bank the Nintendo
Entertainment System technical
limitations ensured that you really
weren't seeing all that much but you
fleshed out the rest with your
imagination then the Nintendo 64 release
and we realized how deeply console games
could communicate a sense of place Super
Mario 64 paves the way for fantastic
games in Nintendo's 3d space offering up
a platform that still stands today is
one of the best it followed in the wake
of PC titles approved we could expand
the ways we looked at games and how we
design levels to create a more engaging
experience for the first time on console
we could really feel the geography we
could really feel the movement we could
look into the distance and say let's go
there but then along came Ocarina of
Time it dropped us into a world of
forest fields massive lakes and rolling
desert as opposed to Mario 64 separate
levels ocarina tide all of its locales
together into one cohesive world for
many reminded them of their time
exploring the original Legend of Zelda
too many ocarina was the idealized
version of that first game it was the
version they saw in their minds i when
Nintendo is Hardware limited what they
were seeing on screen but not what they
imagined it to be
ocarina was a revolution for Nintendo
the Zelda series and video games in
general and now breadth of the wild is
here and I can't stop seeing the
parallels between the two
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was born after the release of the
original Legend of Zelda so like many
players Ocarina was the first time I
felt truly transported it was escapism
yes but it was also first time I
realized that many of the stories we
pull from games are the stories we tell
ourselves I didn't just go to the spirit
temple I cross a blistery sandstorm
fought discussing enemies that rose from
the ground met a ghost who showed me the
way and I realized I could only progress
if I return to the same spot seven years
in the past breath of the wild is the
embodiment of stories like these it's
about the time I barely scale the
slippery cliff in the pouring rain it's
about that time I pulled an enemy arrow
for my shield loaded my bow and fired it
right back it's about that traveler I
met on the road who I never saw again
all of this is to say that for the first
time my wish for what a Zelda could be
had finally aligned with what it really
is I don't have to imagine the grand
adventure here Nintendo had shown it to
me the breath of the wild doesn't just
overshadow every other Zelda game it
overshadows every other open-world game
yes even Metal Gear Solid 5 yes even The
Witcher 3 and yes even Grand Theft Auto
5 horizon zero dawn released the week
before breath of the wild and it is an
excellent game it ties nature and
technology together into a memorable
world and it tells a great story about
the humans of the far future it also
introduces robot hunting mechanics to
set it combat apart from other
third-person titles for a while I
absolutely loved it but then I returned
to it after playing breast of the wild
and something fell off something had
changed I was following my waypoints I
was gathering plans and branches and
machine parts I was hunting massive
mechanical beef but I was just going
through the motions after playing
breadth of the wild horizons world had
lost my interest
that's because breath of the wild uses
its every mechanic it's every
overlapping system to create a more
meaningful sense of place the wilderness
isn't something we just traversed here
it's something we need to survive it's
world map isn't just an arena in which
we fight numerous enemies Hyrule itself
is an enemy to rest of the wild
introduces its survival mechanics within
several moments of link waking up and
walking out into the world
this is Lightspeed by today's standards
where games hold our hand through the
first few hours ensuring that we
understand exactly how much
and exactly how we're supposed to use
them in the future
Zelda games have been guilty of this for
decades but here we are in a Zelda game
and five minutes after the opening
cinematic we are already seeing the
complex cause-and-effect scenarios of
breath of the wild mechanics chain
reaction events usually reserved for the
late game hours of lesser title I
[Music]
originally spoke to Todd Howard designer
a fallout 4 and Elder Scrolls 5 about
what makes a good open-world game and he
said that the best one say yes to the
player more often they allow the player
not just the freedom to explore but the
freedom to tinker with the world on a
whim breath of the wild says yes to the
player all the time
can I climb that cliff yes can I chop
down that tree to make a bridge across
this ravine
yes can I steal the weapons off that
sleeping giants necklace before he wakes
up and chases me across a nearby bridge
of course but just being able to do
these things isn't what makes pres of
the wild so special it's the fact that
these actions are all essential to its
world because this is a harsh world it's
a survival game where the climate your
stamina and your supplies are all major
factors you cook meals to boost your
energy and Don warm clothes to withstand
the cold it's survival mechanics demand
that you both rely on and remain wary of
the wilderness the difficulty of your
enemies on the other hand encourages you
to explore Hyrule every nook and cranny
hoping for better gear to make you
stronger in some cases you'll encounter
foes too strong to handle in your
current state hours later you're better
equipped and better prepared to return
and take your revenge
Hyrule friendly inhabitants are
essential in the open world as well
offering more than just backstory or the
sense of a living world townfolk offer
up rumors warnings or ghost stories that
lead you into the remote places of
Hyrule you explore more StumbleUpon
campfire sneak around it before
declaring it safe this is all an endless
rewarding loop that ties every facet of
the world together
you have an overarching objective but
the simple story contextualizes things
so you don't feel guilty for wandering
the story supports the idea of a lost
hero living off the land linking up with
other champions growing stronger before
finally venturing into the castle in the
distance I'm not just foraging for the
hell of it or moving from Waypoint to
Waypoint I mean this in all honesty but
after all the hours I put into breath of
the wild there is still never a dull
moment and that's the key thing here in
breath of the wild I am always thinking
even as I make my way across a flat
filled with almost no focal points in
sight I'm thinking five steps ahead how
many arrows do I have do I need to make
camp and cook food how close is this
weapon to degrading what happens at beau
Cobb when cavalry attacked me out of
nowhere should I head for those cliffs
to get out of the open this is all to
say that breath of the wild is an open
world not just for the sake of it
because it's a major trend in recent
years its open-world because Nintendo
wanted to impart the feeling of being on
a dangerous adventure and every system
at play here feeds into that idea this
is a massive Hyrule we're exploring but
there is not much filler at all
I love The Witcher 3 is branching web of
storylines I love the absurdity and
freedom of Grand Theft Auto 5 I love the
immersion moments as Metal Gear Solid 5
but I think we've all grown weary of
open-world games in recent years we've
become tired of comparing map sizes or
checking off boxes on an ever growing
list of fetch quest but breast is a wild
like ocarina of time before it or The
Legend of Zelda before that came along
to upset the status quo a came at a time
when video games were oversaturated with
open worlds and we all forgot what made
them so magical to begin with been a
while since a Legend of Zelda game as
challenge appears but breath of a while
just arrived and it brought clear
message open world games can be
interesting again
[Music]
me
hey everyone thanks so much for watching
our second episode of reboot on breath
of the wild you haven't yet like and
subscribe it helps us keep doing these
and we really enjoy doing them it is a
biweekly show and in the off week we do
a Q&A in our past episode as well as
teaser next episode so get your YouTube
comments in tweet at Jake Decker or me
we might feature your comments on the
show in our off weeks so get those in
and we're looking forward to seeing you